y llantas quemadas y calles bloqueadas
en puerto príncipe- consecuencia del
descontento social generalizado miles de
haitianos exigieron acciones al gobierno
para contrarrestar la violencia y la
subida de los precios
cada vez que quieren subir el precio de
combustible alegan que hay escasez eso
no es cierto hay existencias no hay
necesidad de causar dolor a la gente si
se empeñan en subir los precios del
petróleo prendemos fuego al país y todos
desaparecerán
las pandillas g9 y gpp se disputan el
control de la comuna cité soleil a las
afueras de la capital la violencia
derivó en el cierre de la terminal de
combustible bajo preocupaciones de
seguridad que se traducen en estaciones
de gasolina vacías la escasez ha
disparado sus precios con el galón de la
gasolina a más de 12 dólares en el
mercado negro aumentando el costo de
vida algo que se suma a la escalada de
la violencia en la nación caribeña
según la ong red nacional de defensa de
los derechos humanos al menos 89 y han
sido asesinadas y 16 desaparecidas en la
última semana
es difícil no hay manera de vivir hay
muchas balas volando por todas partes
dentro de la casa no estamos seguros y
tampoco podemos salir imagínate lo que
pasaría si saliéramos
factores que ponen en riesgo a la
población del país más pobre del
continente en el que según naciones
unidas al menos 13 millones de personas
se enfrentan a la inseguridad
alimentaria de emergencia y la
inseguridad alimentaria de emergencia es
la última de las 5 que es la fase más
extrema lo que llamamos hambruna
precariedad que ha aumentado la
sensación de descontrol en haití
disparada desde el magnicidio del
presidente yo en el mois hace un año